[Applaudissements]
bon je vais commencer
une histoire qui commence par biologique
et qui se termine par une invention que
vous connaissez tous et que vous portez
même peut-être sur vous on né en 1941 et
en ingénieur suisse georges de mestral
part se balader en forêt avec son chien
seulement à son retour de sa balade ils
se retrouvent à enlever des dizaines de
petits fruits de bardane qui sont
accrochées aux poils de son chien si je
vous parle de la bardane peut-être que
ça ne vous évoque rien et pourtant vous
la connaissez tout pousse c'est elle et
je pense que vous voyez aussi très bien
de quoi je parle quand je parle des
fruits de bardane ces petits fruits
marron épineux qui s'accrochent un peu
partout quand on se base balade elle en
campagne qui s'accrochent dans les
vêtements qui s'accrochent dans les
poils des animaux parfois même dans les
cheveux sauf qu'à ce moment là georges
de mestral est assez interpellé par la
performance c'est un végétal et il est
très tenace très difficile à enlever
dans les poils de son chien alors ce
qu'il va le faire à ce moment-là c'est
exploiter son sa curiosité et observer
le fruit de bardane au microscope
voilà ce qu'il découvre
il découvre que le fruit de la bardane
est entouré par des centaines de petites
épines qui se termine par des crochets
des centaines de crochets microscopiques
qui sont souples et déformables pourquoi
c'est intéressant parce que la forme en
crochet je pense que c'est assez évident
pour tout le monde permet de s'accrocher
au fil des tissus aux poils des animaux
à différents types de surface
mais l'aspect souple et déformable fait
que lorsqu'on retire le crochet de la
bardane ce temps et reprend ensuite sa
forme initiale c'est en fait un système
d'attaché souple et réversible
et à partir de cette observation
georges de mestral va inventer le velcro
plus communément appelée le scratch
le scratch et donc inspiré d'un végétal
inspirées de l'observation d'un
scientifique qui a compris qu'un système
biologique pouvait être assez performant
pour développer une nouvelle technologie
alors pourquoi je vous parle de ça
aujourd'hui pourquoi je vous raconte
cette histoire parce que ce que georges
de mestral a fait ça s'appelle du bio
mimétisme le biomimétisme sim discipline
qui consiste à s'inspirer du vivant pour
innover le biomimétisme c'est une
approche de recherche et de
développement qui consiste à s'inspirer
de l'ingéniosité des mécanismes des
organismes biologiques pour transformer
les technologies actuelles le
biomimétisme c'est ces hommes ces femmes
ces ingénieurs ces biologistes
physiciens et chimistes
qui ont décidé d'explorer le monde du
vivant pour innover et bien c'est ce que
je vous propose de faire avec moi ce
soir d'explorer le vivant de partir à la
découverte du monde du vivant pour
découvrir le biomimétisme vous faire
sentir ce que c'est que le biomimétisme
à travers mes yeux et comment je le vois
alors comment j'ai découvert le
biomimétisme c'est assez rigolo
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai découvert le
biomimétisme exactement à votre place on
est le 31 janvier 2019 à ce moment là je
suis encore étudiante à l'agro et
j'assiste aux tedx luminescence je suis
donc exactement à votre place lorsqu on
m'explique qu'il y à une discipline qui
existent et qui permet de s'inspirer du
hérisson du pamplemousse pour développer
un casque de vélo on peut s'inspirer du
martin pêcheur pour développer un
nouveau système de train alors je suis
assez interpellé pour tout vous dire
parce que c'est des organismes que je
connais le hérisson le pamplemousse et
pourtant je n'avais aucune idée que ça
pouvait inspirer des technologies
et bien deux ans plus tard je suis tombé
par hasard sur une publication de bio de
segi bureau d'études et d'ingénierie
spécialisée en biologie
et bien j'ai décidé d'en faire mon
métier
le biomimétisme c'est ce que je fais
tous les jours j'explore le monde qui
m'entoure j'explore le vivant pour
imaginer concevoir et développer de
nouvelles technologies
alors c'est mon métier c'est bien joli
mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire qu'est
ce que ça veut dire de faire du
biomimétisme son métier et bien si je
dois expliquer sommairement
succinctement en partenaire industriel
nous présente une problématique ça peut
être des problèmes type de tout laisser
de tous les secteurs des problématiques
techniques scientifiques
on va par exemple vous poser la question
comment je pourrais me défaire de la
corrosion dans les canalisations comment
je pourrais améliorer la résilience de
systèmes de détection comment je
pourrais produire des couleurs sans
utiliser de pigments chimiques
une fois qu'on m'a exposé cette
problématique je la comprends je me
l'approprié et ensuite je vais chercher
dans le vivant
s'il n'y a pas un organisme biologique
qui a déjà résolu cette problématique
s'il n'y a pas une stratégie dans le
vivant qui existent et qui me
permettrait de solutionner le problème
une fois que j'ai identifié cette
stratégie et il y en a toujours ou
presque toujours je me je la comprends
et je vais la transposer alors attention
il s'agit pas ici de faire du
copier-coller biomimétisme c'est comme
j'ai dit c'est s'inspirer de la nature
pour innover
mon rôle consiste donc à développer des
technologies inspiré du vivant alors je
vais vous donner un exemple pour
concrétiser un petit peu ce que je viens
de dire un jour un acteur des transports
en commun est venu nous voir avec la
problématique suivante
comment diminuer l'empreinte énergétique
de mes systèmes de ventilation parce que
les transports en commun c'est des
centaines de kilomètres de tunnels et
donc il faut brasser des grandes masses
d'air pour ce faire ils ont des grands
système de soufflerie du cd gros
ventilateur il y en a des centaines à
paris on les voit pas mais ils sont bien
là bien ces ventilateurs datent souvent
des années 70 ils font beaucoup de bruit
et consomment beaucoup d'énergie
et bien avec mes équipes on travaille
aujourd'hui sur un système de
ventilation inspiré des baleines à bosse
économes en énergie alors s'inspirer des
baleines pour développer des systèmes de
ventilation comment ça marche alors tout
d'abord les baleines sont des mammifères
marins qui sont extrêmement agile dans
l'eau les baleines à bosses sont des
prédateurs pour se nourrir se nourrir
elles doivent chasser
elles doivent aller trouver des
crustacés des petits poissons du krill
et donc elles doivent aller très vite ce
qu'elles ont les baleines à bosse
s'appelle le tubercule c'est exactement
ce que vous voyez sur le board attaques
de la nageoire
les petites bosses que l'on voit
s'appelle des tubercules et leur
répartition leur forme leur taille mais
pas laissé au hasard ce qui est
intéressant lorsqu'on
n'approfondit un petit peu lorsqu'on
explore un petit peu plus le vivant dont
comprendre les tubercules permettent en
fait de créer
des petits tourbillons à la surface des
nageoires de baleines à bosse c'est
petit tourbillon permettent d'augmenter
la portance la portance c'est la force
qui s'applique perpendiculairement au
mans c'est ce qui permet un avion de
volée par exemple et ça permet de
diminuer la traînée la traînée c'est la
force qui s'opposa mouvement veulent
assimilés à des frottements donc les
tubercules qui sont présents sur les
nageurs de baleines à bosse en
permettant d'augmenter la portance et de
diminuer la traînée lui confère son
agilité
eh bien c'est exactement de ça dont il
s'inspire aujourd'hui on sent nous
sommes en train de développer des
ventilateurs avec des pales tubercule
est inspiré des nageoires de baleines à
bosse pour réduire leur bruit et réduire
leur consommation énergétique
c'est incroyablement sincèrement qui ici
se doutait qu'on pouvait s'inspirer des
nageurs de baleines à bosse pour
développer des systèmes de ventilation
économes en énergie
ça me fait venir à mon deuxième point le
biomimétisme pour moi c'est ma passion
c'est ma passion parce qu'au quotidien
j'explore le vivant et je découvre je
découvre des organismes biologiques
absolument incroyable je vais vous
présenter un les organismes favori
je vous présente moloch taurus
le diable cornu alors c'est un petit
lézard qui vient en australie d'à peine
dix centimètres il vit dans les régions
arides et en plus d'avoir ce qu'on
pourrait appeler un physique atypique il
a une manière de boire très particulière
moloko readius vit en australie dans les
régions arides et comme vous pouvez vous
en douter l'hydratation est un enjeu
capital pour la survie de l'organisme eh
bien il a la capacité de lorsqu'il met
ses pattes dans l'eau d'arriver à boire
alors comment ça fonctionne il a en fait
à la surface de son organisme des
centaines de micro canaux qui permettent
à l'eau de remontée de ses pattes par
capillarité jusqu'à sa gueule la
capillarité c'est le phénomène physique
que vous observez quand vous trempez un
sopalin dans l'eau par exemple vous
voyez look herman tu sais exactement ce
qui se passe à l'as sur les pattes de
mollo coryne husse mais c'est pas tout
parce que ces épines du cerveau lui
servent aussi en plus de lui donner un
sacré style elles lui permettent de
récolter l'eau qui est contenue dans
l'air comment ça se passe et bien lui
mine et l humidité de l'air l'eau
contenue dans l'air va venir ce condensé
sur ses épines lorsque la température du
lézard est inférieure à la température
extérieure on va donc avoir la formation
de gouttes d'eau sur ses épines qui vont
ensuite être acheminés par les micros
canaux dont je vous parlais à l'instant
jusqu'à sa gueule et bien au moloko
readius le diable cornu est aujourd'hui
à l'étude pour développer une tour
collectrices d'eau potable dont les
régions arides
un lézard
un petit lézard est donc en train d'être
étudiées pour aller récolter l'humidité
de l'air la stocker et donner accès à
l'eau potable dans des aires c'est
incroyable et bien je vous parle de
moloko readius mais j'aurais pu vous
parler du saphir ina qui parvient à se
rendre invisible juste en changeant
d'épaisseur j'aurais pu vous parler de
la vision incroyable de la crevette
mende qui voit d'ailleurs beaucoup plus
de couleurs que nous sommes capables
aujourd'hui j'aurais pu aussi vous
parler de la salle à manger en chine qui
a une peau avec des propriétés auto
cicatrisante grâce à des diversités de
protéines
j'aurais pu vous parler tout ça parce
que mon quotidien c'est d'explorer le
vivant de découvrir des organismes
biologiques absolument phénoménale avec
des propriétés qui sont bluffantes
mais aussi le biomimétisme ça m'a fait
comprendre que la nature elle sait tout
faire et le fait bien mieux que nous si
on fait un bilan juste pour rigoler
exploiter l'énergie solaire les plantes
le maîtrisent à la perfection
nous sommes encore en train d'essayer
nature 1 1 0
produire de l'eau potable à partir d'eau
salée les mangroves savent le faire nous
sommes encore en train d'essayer nature
2 1 0
climatisé sa maison sans utiliser
d'énergie les termites savent le faire
au construisant leur termitière sommes
encore en train d'essayer nature trois
hommes 0 je vais m'arrêter là parce que
sinon on ne sera encore demain puis
l'objectif n'est pas de faire un match
nature vs humanité déjà parce qu'ils
seraient perdus d'avancé mais en plus
parce que c'est pas ça l'objectif du bio
8 biomimétisme c'est s'inspirer de la
nature pour innover le biomimétisme ça
consiste à prendre conscience que la
nature elle a encore beaucoup à nous
apprendre et je découvre au quotidien
des propriétés absolument incroyable et
d'ailleurs mes proches m'ont un peu
marque chaque fois qu'on se voie j'ai
une nouvelle anecdote biologique à
l'heure à compter sur le fait que la
fourmi argenté du sahara elle arrive à
réguler sa température seulement grâce à
la forme de ses poils ou que
contrairement à ce que l'on croit le
caméléon il change de couleur plutôt
pour réguler sa température que pour se
camoufler la nature a encore tout à nous
apprendre et c'est pour ça que pour moi
le biomimétisme c'est une promesse c'est
une problème technique une promesse
technologique comment la nature regarde
comment la nature en temps comment elles
se déplacent comment elle produit de
l'énergie comment elle produit de la
lumière comment elles génèrent les
couleurs comment la nature recycle
comment la nature fait pour c'est la
base du biomimétisme
comment la nature fait pour parce que la
nature ces trois ou plus de 3 milliards
d'années d'évolution
c'est un laboratoire de recherche et
développement de plus de 3 milliards
d'années dont le processus de criblage
n'est autre que la sélection naturelle
si une solution biologique a été
sélectionné parmi des centaines de
milliers d'autres pendant des centaines
de milliers d'années elle est
performante
et pourtant avec un petit peu de recul
et un chouïa d'humilité on se rend
compte qu'on s'échine depuis plus d'un
siècle a révolutionné le monde ans
l'artiste à lisant en se détachant au
maximum de la biodiversité et de la
nature pourquoi ça parce que nous
humains se considère comme la meilleure
espèce l'espèce la plus évoluée l'espèce
la plus attachante la plus intelligente
et la plus douée
alors qu'avec un petit peu de recul en
explorant un peu plus mais surtout un
peu mieux on se rend compte de
l'absurdité de ce postulat tout n'est
qu'une question de point de vue et de
regards et c'est pour ça que le
biomimétisme pour moi est aussi une
promesse de réconcilier nature et
technologie
biodiversité et innovation pourquoi
parce que le biomimétisme nous permet de
changer le regard qu'on porte sur le
monde du vivant l'odieux le biomimétisme
nous permet d'être émerveillé face à la
biodiversité à son ingéniosité
partir du moment où on comprend qu'en
étudiant un petit lézard on arrive à
récolter de l'eau potable dans le désert
on fait attention à ce petit lézard
partir du moment où on comprend que la
nature la biodiversité est un moteur
pour innover on fait attention à ne pas
la détruire et je vous ai présenté là
qu'un échantillon microscopique de ce
qui existe dans le monde vivant la
biodiversité c'est deux millions
d'espèces plus de 2 millions d'espèces
connues et des millions d'espèces qui
reste à découvrir
croyez-moi le monde du vivant n'a pas
fini de vous surprendre et le
biomimétisme non plus merci à tous
[Applaudissements]